[Música]
brasileiros em uma mobilete
[Aplausos]
bem vindo ao ted x não é um amigo mas é
quase tão bonito evento tão bonitas
pessoas
a gente colocou a ontem no final do dia
um podcast sobre o fracasso e eu pedi
pra tv 2 semana que vem para eu contar o
que eu fiz aqui eu faço podcast por um
motivo bem interessante não ter que
mostrar a minha cara
então como a gente teve palestrante aqui
que trouxe música trouxe som eu digo
vocês fecharem os olhos e apenas houve
nenhum fã pode ser bom
eu tenho um pouco tempo pra contar uma
história enorme bom o mamilos é a gente
se denomina jornalismo de peito aberto e
aí eu vim contar pra vocês
o qual é a nossa perspectiva quando a
gente diz isso
o mario começa em 2014 e na época tinha
16 m famoso né
nessa hora não é porque a gente nem acho
que fazer sucesso e colocou o nome de m
num programa que hoje ninguém mais
conhece o meme
então a gente recebe e ficou esse nome
por uma coisa que passou a fazer muito
sentido por mamilos maneiros alimentam a
mil são polêmicos mamilo são tabus que
precisam ser desnudadas então é esse
tipo de conversa que toda semana a gente
leva para as pessoas a atingir esse
peito aberto essa idéia a gente conectou
a nossa conversa uma um slogan tá pra
gente tem um rumo sempre olhar para
aquilo
nós estamos mais preocupados em criar
pontes do que improvável pontos
pontes do que provar pontos que que isso
quer dizer
bom começa pela escolha dos temas quando
a gente vai escolher um tema no mamilo
a gente entende hoje em dia que tá tudo
muito inflamado né a gente leu uma
notícia e fica horas ruminando aquilo e
faz muito mal porque a gente está
vivendo muito na cultura da indignação
eu vivi indignado eu vejo aquilo fica
indignado eu leio isso e fica indignado
não dá tempo de procurar essa inflamação
para mim outra indignação e me deixou
indignado e indignação ela suga sua
energia e você fica tão exausto e chega
no final do dia se acha que nada vale a
pena a gente decidiu fazer um jornalismo
anti inflamatório
então a nossa conversa vai justamente
para narrativas restaurativa em um
jornalismo de paz
o que isso quer dizer a gente é fita em
citar qualquer tipo de discurso de ódio
discriminação e violência
uma outra coisa que a gente aprendeu
muito rápido mamilos é que quando a
gente foca indivíduos
as pessoas tendem a acreditar que
eliminando indivíduo a gente elimina o
problema dentro dessas narrativas
restaurativa
nós entendemos que era importante
aprofundar a conversa para conversar
sobre a infraestrutura sobre a sociedade
e quando a gente traz as pessoas para
esse convite de pensar mais intenso
elas entendem com compaixão a
necessidade da mudança do todo é isso
aconteceu em episódios muitos muitos
episódios mais alguns específicos eu
lembro muito quando aconteceu o
assassinato da marielly e todo mundo
focado muito no assassinato em si ea
gente decidiu trazer uma conversa sobre
direitos humanos o que é afinal direitos
humanos porque é a forma que nós
entendemos de perpetuar o discurso que a
pessoa que nós acabávamos de perder
trabalhava tanto para fazer
e foi nesse tipo de discurso ea gente
começa uma narrativa restaurativa
isso significa pensarmos juntos caminhos
para melhorar daqui chega no final do
dia a luz esteja acesa e vocês possam
ver e quando a gente vê não dá pra dizer
não dá para arrumar tudo mas a luz já
foi ligada ea partir do momento que a
luz foi ligada a gente começa juntos a
entender como a gente pode se movimentar
pra organizar então os temas tem sempre
esse recorte da polêmica não pela
polêmica não para lacrar o mago
ventilatório
a gente conversa para conectar para
mostrar nossa humanidade para mostrar
que tem gente envolvido
a segunda coisa que a gente faz numa
menos pra ele ser um jornalismo de peito
aberto é se abrir para os convidados
os convidados no mamilo sair a gente já
passou ali com muitas pessoas são sempre
pessoas que têm algo de importante para
dizer mas tem um outro pressuposto para
assentar na nossa mesa
são pessoas interessadas em ouvir é
sempre esse recorte quando a gente vai
fazer um convite para pessoas que são
curiosas e para pessoas que querem expor
o que acreditam como o recorte aqui já
foi feito pra gente é trazer essas
pessoas é óbvio que ela já vem com o
pressuposto do programa que é sentar
numa mesa e conversar sobre fatos trazer
percepções e inspirar para soluções
então todo mundo que vem já vem muito
preparado pra isso e mesmo pessoas que
em outros canais a gente acaba
assistindo essas pessoas com um discurso
mais enfático quando chega no mamilo céu
sempre estão muito dispostas a conversar
e também a ouvir essas pessoas não
representam crise jô
ela se apresentou muito mais do que isso
ela sempre representa a pluralidade de
visões sobre o mesmo tema
e é aí
traz um monte de pessoas pra mesa que
falam muitas vezes coisas que
particularmente eu crise não acredito
nas pessoas já ouviram falar assim se
fazer um treinamento para não dar um
soco na cara da pessoa quando ela fala
um absurdo não a gente não vá a um
treinamento mas a gente faz um exercício
verdadeiro de curiosidade pelo outro de
ouvir o outro para entender de onde ele
estava olhando que eu não percebi qual é
a trajetória dele que leva a acreditar
em algo tão diferente do que eu acredito
então esse recorte dos convidados sempre
trouxe pessoas muito interessantes para
a mesa mas aí a gente tem um outro
sentido pra fazer o jornalismo de peito
aberto que somos nós
eu ea juliana quando a gente senta ali a
gente senta realmente com um olhar de
curiosa e exploradora
a cada semana a gente faz um mergulho e
sair falando outros idiomas é fazer um
programa sobre gordon fobia fazer um
programa sobre vacina fazer um programa
sobre greve dos caminhoneiros nos leva a
visita universos que a gente nunca tinha
ido antes a nossa desconstrução tá na
mesa a nota o nosso questionamento sobre
as nossas verdades está na mesa e esse
convite que a gente faz para a audiência
querem explorar conosco querem ser
curioso conosco querem complementar
conosco e é essa mediação e é essa nossa
vulnerabilidade exposta para vocês
porque às vezes não dá certo porque às
vezes a gente chama uma pessoa para
participar que tem um currículo incrível
mas chega lá no rende tanto nem outra
pessoa que a gente conversou não pareceu
muito mais 0 que dava pra fazer dentro
daquela hora daquela semana naquele tema
chega lá a pessoa abre a boca e saem
pássaros
então essa imprevisibilidade da conversa
na presente na mesa e espanha nossa
vulnerabilidade
então a gente já chorou eu chutei a mesa
e perdi uma hora de gravação
de madrugada e tive que olhar para as
pessoas e falar ações podem gravar de
novo comigo ea gente tem bem mais sorte
que juízo porque as pessoas topam eu
costumo falar que a gente é doida mas
tem muito mais maluco por aí gente que é
desembargador médico e jurista é
estudiosos que simplesmente recebem uma
ligação de uma das garotas que se dizem
podcast fazer um programa chamado
mamilos e se dispõe a 'conversa' então
cada vez que isso acontece cada pequeno
milagre que acontece toda semana a gente
percebe que na nossa sociedade no brasil
nem muita gente querendo conversar
tem muita gente querendo entender como
pensa e colocar também o seu ponto de
vista e isso vai para o terceiro ponto
que a nossa comunidade
a gente faz um jornalismo dito
colaborativo porque a audiência que é o
nosso dedo no pulso
são essas pessoas que toda semana
escutam o programa e as pessoas falam
mas mamilos que nome estranho o que isso
não não quer saber e ouvir essas pessoas
também entram em contato e complementam
o conteúdo de uma maneira única
uma experiência muito recente a gente
fez um programa sou pornografia e de
novo voltando na vulnerabilidade a gente
não conseguiu formar uma mesa tão plural
quanto a gente gostaria de ter formado
com muitos pontos de vistas mas no na
semana seguinte uma ouvinte escrever um
conto a pão um contraponto deste tamanho
que dá pra perceber que ela ficou um
tempo lhe elaborando aquilo e ficou tão
bom que a gente entrou em contato com
ela pediu para mandar isso como áudio
voltou no programa editou incluiu o
contraponto dela para o conteúdo é mais
plural mais diverso mais restaurativo e
trazer outros pontos de vista
o que a gente faz é muito legal mas o
que as pessoas fazem como amigos é
infinitamente mais legal
então a gente faz um programa sobre os
desafios da democracia
e recebe um email de um ouvinte do
interior de goiás que está fazendo
psicologia e trabalha fixa no outdoor
falando eu vou eu vou entrar hoje na
faculdade disposto a reabrir o grêmio
porque a gente precisa sentar e
conversar sobre melhoria na instituição
lágrimas semana seguinte a gente faz um
programa sobre pagamos impostos demais
uma média discussão técnica chegam e
meio de um ouvinte falando
houve esse problema e vou separar do meu
marido dela explica
me explica como que você chegou aí então
ele sempre ele tem um ponto de vista
muito diferentes sobre como a gente vai
construir uma sociedade mais justa e eu
acabei descobrindo que eu sou muito boa
com dinheiro eu quero a minha
independência
é isso que a gente recebe toda semana eu
choro toda semana as pessoas falar eu
chorei ouvindo você falou eu também
chorei está tudo bem
são esses temas com esses convidados com
a nossa nosso desejo de conectar com
essa comunidade que a gente faz
jornalismo de peito aberto ea gente faz
isso porque nós acreditamos nas pessoas
e nas conexões e nas pontes que nós
vamos construir é pra isso que a gente
está ali para mediar não dá pra ser
isento isenção é uma mentira ela não
existe
mas dá pra ser honesto intelectualmente
e trazer pessoas com pontos de vista
diferentes num espaço sem animosidade
para que cada um possa expor seu ponto
de vista porque a gente acredita na
inteligência dessa gente que está
ouvindo e que vai ouvir pontos diferente
e vai sair dali e criar o seu próprio
ponto de partida então a gente não dá
verdades prontas a gente dá curiosidade
pesquisa interação e conexão
isso é jornalismo de peito aberto é isso
que a gente tem convidado as pessoas
toda semana para fazer o que a gente
entende que são nessas conversas
restauradora
vamos nos conectar e nos encontrar
enquanto pessoas tem choro em chute na
mesa tem voz ruim tem mais o que tem
muito e mail um bom pra ler nem muita
gente bacana pra conversar e isso
restaura a nossa fé num lugar que a
gente está todo dia e nas pessoas que
estão ali toda semana ouvindo isso é uma
- essa é a mensagem de criar pontes mais
do que provar pontos
esse é o que a gente faz toda semana nos
últimos quatro anos a quase 190
programas com mais de 400 convidados já
passando pela mesa mais de 300 minutos
de gravação para mais de 150 mil pessoas
a cada episódio
esse é o nosso jornalismo de peito
aberto
obrigada
[Aplausos]